Mirna Djukic.travailleurs
de soutien de l'éducation sont
de nouveau sortis au sortis au s
pour se faire entendre à
Toronto. Parmi eux, Ron
Fergusonique du Conseil scolaire
du district de Toronto, dit que
péciale, adoptée plus
tôt cette semaine, ne l'a pas
découragé.
"Je serai probablement encore
pour défendre mes droits de la
seule façon possible," dit-il.
À ses côtés samedi se trouvaient
des collègues du Syndicat
publique, mais aussi des
enseignants et des
du public.à
et moi je suis avec eux.
La fermeture c'est pas bien,
mais s'ils ont pas le choix.
Il faut aider les profsl'éducatn
nationale.e.e.e.
- De nomscolaires, ont passé
à l'enseignement en ligne
pour le moment, prétextant des
enjeux de sécurité. En absence
d'entretien et autres
travailleurs de soutien.
Ce ne fut toutefois pas le cas
Viamonde. Tard jeudi, une lettre
a été envoyé aux employés
pour leur rappelés qu'ils
étaient tous attendus a l'école
la grève s'exposeraient
potentiellement a s
de 4000 dollars par jour,
en vertu de la nouvelle loi.
du gouvernement, mais
qui a choqué certains parents.
- Ils prennent positionu
de défendre, ou au moins
de s'excde s'excde s'excde s'ex,
comme j'ai dit auparavant,
inacceptable, dégoutant.
Pour moi personnellement,
ils auraient juste dû dire rien.
- Viamonde n'a pas répondudio-C.
De son côté, le gouvernement
ontarien martèle que s'il adopte
la ligne dure avec le syndicat,
c'est parce qu'il nt éviter nt s
de perturbations aux cours
en classe.
Ici Mirna Djukic,